President Biden
overnight racing back to Washington
for debt limit negotiations.
Just hours from now,
he is set to once again
meet with House Speaker Kevin McCarthy.
At the White House.
There's less than ten days left now
to reach a deal and prevent
a catastrophic default.
House Republicans
are demanding huge spending cuts
before the president left Japan.
He told reporters
the latest proposal from the Republicans
was, quote, unacceptable.
I can't guarantee that
they wouldn't force a default
by doing something outrageous.
I can't guarantee that.
I think there are some
major Republicans in the House
who know the damage
that it would do to the economy.
And because I am president and president
is responsible for everything,
Biden would take the blame.
And that's the one way to make sure
Biden is not reelected.
Biden McCarthy spoke
while the president
was flying home
on Air Force
One, and McCarthy called
that talk productive.
We're covering all angles.
Let's begin with warm Fox tracking,
tracking developments on Capitol Hill
and our left signs at the White House
are let to you.
The president cut his trip short,
cut off
two important legs of the trip
so he could be in Washington
for what is going to happen today.
What do we expect?
Well, Poppy,
President Biden
returned to Washington
in much
the same way that he left it
without any clear resolution
in sight
to avert a default in
as little as ten days.
But a bit later today,
President Biden and House Speaker
Kevin McCarthy will sit down
for another high stakes
meeting
really highlighting
the urgency of this moment.
The two of them spoke on the phone
yesterday as the president
traveled back on Air Force One.
And that led to negotiators
from both sides
coming to the negotiating table
last night on Capitol Hill.
The two sides met
for about two and a half hours.
They look to work through
some of the very vast
differences that remain
when it comes to trying
to reach a budget agreement.
And one of those key
sticking points has been around
spending levels as the White House
wants to keep
spending at the current year's levels
while Republicans
want to see it cut back
and reverted back to fiscal year.
2022.
But but the president over the weekend
really highlighted that he believes
that the Republicans proposals recently
that were recently
put forth over the weekend
that they amount to extreme positions.
And it is the White House's belief
that Republicans
need to realize
that this needs to be a bipartisan deal
which will require compromise
and some movement from GOP positions.
But bottom line here,
the president,
Speaker McCarthy, are facing
very serious time constraints.
Yesterday
We heard Treasury Secretary
Janet Yellen once again reaffirm
that she believes the U.S.
could default on its debts
as early as June.
First really highlighting the urgency
the fact that this is a very fast
moving situation
and really that the leaders
that President Biden
and Speaker
McCarthy need to act very quickly
in order to avert a default.
But for the time being,
it's still remains
that it still appears
to be that the differences are vast.
Let's go to Lauren now.
Earlier, Poppy mentioned
that McCarthy
has a very narrow majority in the House.
How does this impact his strategy
as he goes into this meeting?
I mean, we are at crunch time now.
Yes, I
mean, he just
doesn't have the kind of negotiating room
that he would have
if he had a larger Republican majority
in the back of his mind
has to be
this reality
that he is going
to lose conservative votes
if he actually makes a bipartisan deal
with President Joe Biden.
And that calculus,
whether or not
he is going to be willing
to potentially
put his speakership on the line
for that deal
is something that is looming large
in these negotiations.
Also looming
large is the reality that these two men
have a very untested relationship.
They really haven't spent that
much one on one time together.
They never spent that much time
in the previous two years
when Biden was president and
you had McCarthy,
who was in the minority at that point.
So there is a huge question mark
right now,
whether or not
their relationship
really can get this deal
over the finish line,
like Arlette mentioned.
The negotiations
over the weekend
happened in fits and starts
with both sides trading back and forth.
Proposals that the other side argued
were unreasonable.
I talked to one Republican last night
who told me that they feel like right now
this deal is just hanging by a thread.
Whether or not
they can actually find a way forward
is a major question mark.
And like you noted,
time is running short
to move this through.
The House of Representatives
would take several days,
at least 72 hours
for members to look at a plan
and then vote on it in the Senate.
It could take even longer.
Now, that's always possible.
That they could move more expeditiously.
But as Kevin McCarthy
noted over the weekend,
he has been planning
for potentially the Senate
to need seven days.
Maybe they need less than that.
But that just gives you a sense
of how short we are running on time.
Wow. Seven days.
So ten -7 is three so that means, Lauren,
they got three days to figure this out.
But that's the big question right now.
And I think that it's always
possible things
move much more quickly in the Senate
when they need to.
But McCarthy has been arguing
he thought they might need a whole week.
Thank you both.
I can't believe you're doing
math at this hour,
but that's really good.
That's what we have.
Christine Romans here
for goodness for her.
My deep sighs over here.
I know
you have been talking about this
ad nauseum over and over and over again,
but you said something that really sent
shivers down my spine.
You said that
if we didn't pass the debt limit,
that we would see our living standards
go back in time.
This is for every American. Yes.
This is incredibly dangerous
what's happening here right now
and how close we are.
$56 billion in the bank this morning.
And we have a bunch of bills
are going to be coming due next month.
Will be money coming in
from state tax receipts and the like
to be playing it
this close is just really,
really dangerous
for the American economy.
So what do I mean about living standards
going back in time
you could have
a 10th of economic activity just stop.
The minute that they do this 10th of so
you have the Treasury Department
that will be having
a Hunger Games of sorts
of which bills to pay.
So you're talking about IOUs
for service members. That's one option.
You could have
delays and Social Security checks.
So think about the senior
who relies on the Social Security check,
who then can't go to the bodega
to buy the milk
and the bread for the week,
who then the bodega
then doesn't have that income.
I mean,
it just starts to all go down
the food chain
and it's very dangerous
to say nothing of what it means
for financial security.
Remember, the entire global
financial system
is built on the American Treasury bond.
And this is something
that the world hungers for.
They go
have they buy as safety our bonds.
It's not a sign of weakness.
Everybody it's a sign of strength
that the American
this security is so sought
after around the world,
you start to undermine the
underpinning of that.
You hurt the dollar.
Instability.
The dollar is very good
for America's competitors. Like China.
I mean,
the whole thing is just a real hot mess.
There are former colleague
Lydia DePillis, who's now
there are times
I thought we wrote a great piece
over the weekend about,
you know,
essentially you're
talking about our creditors.
And if they see us default
on our payments to our service members,
elderly Americans on Social Security,
they've got to be thinking we are next.
And so that upends the whole system
of the full faith and credit of the U.S.
government and
that the dollar should be
the reserve currency. Right? Exactly.
And that's how that plays into China's
hands or plays into
the hands of competitors
who would like to see a world
that's not based on the dollar
where the US Treasury
isn't isn't the king of the hill.
And it is the king of the Hill.
Look, the
US will pay
interest on its debt, I'm sure.
I mean debt holders.
I mean, that would just be devastating
if they defaulted on those obligations.
But to do that,
you have to make big cuts and sacrifices
elsewhere.
That just is a sign of weakness,
a sign of poor planning. As I look.
There is a serious discussion
about America's national debt
growing so large
that chokes our country
in the decades in the future.
That's serious.
Conversation is not had around a debt
ceiling drama.
It's had
serious bipartisan discussions
in the budgeting process.
So we're not doing that right now.
And I think
that there are some Republicans
and there are some Democrats
who think that that's what
we're having a conversation.
We're having a conversation
about spending priorities.
This is money that's already been spent.
Right.
The spending priority conversation
has to happen
in a much more meaningful way than this.
This is distraction.
This is not discipline.
This is drama.
What you're seeing here,
I am old enough to remember
the deficit clock ticking down.
We were in front of it this weekend.
I went this weekend to
I saw a show on Broadway
and in the theater district.
They had it there.
And it's just stuck right
at 31.4 trillion.
But you're right.
I remember what I was going to do
until now.
It's stuck at 31.14
and needs to be raised
or all of us are going to have
all of us are going to feel it
either in your shock investments
or your senior citizens.
Pell Grant. So much.
All of it.
Christine Romans, thank you so much.